weary residents woke to buildings still
ablaze after another night of more
russian bombardment
this is what's left of one of the
university buildings in ukraine's second
largest city after being pounded by
russian air and rocket strikes
and other cities have been hit too this
is in erp
to the north west of kiev locals say
this is a residential neighborhood
the russian advance on ukraine's capital
kiev continues although slowed by heavy
resistance from ukrainian fighters
[Music]
the russians say they are making
advances claiming to have taken the
southern ukrainian city of curson
its military has issued this video of
helicopter operations taking place in
ukraine but have not detailed exact
locations or sites
ukrainian emergency services have
released this video of the aftermath of
yesterday evening's attack on kiev's
freedom square
the city's iconic tv tower was a target
but ukraine's president says it was also
a deliberate attempt to erase the
country's history
a holocaust memorial to the massacre of
thousands of jews stands
ukraine's telecommunications are an
obvious target
sky news has verified this video of the
aftermath of an airstrike on another tv
tower this time english chance in the
east
and this footage of a missile strike was
taken in the same city
the target this time apparently a local
brewery
i want to welcome to our gallery the
ukraine ambassador
you're right
the bravery shown by ukrainians has
inspired the world
in westminster the house of commons
stood to applaud the country's
ambassador who's out watching in the
gallery
what we have seen already uh from
vladimir putin's regime in the use of
the munitions that they have already
been uh they've been dropping on as on
innocent civilians uh mr speaker uh in
my view already fully qualifies as as a
war crime and i know that the uh that
the icc prosecutor is already
investigating i'm sure the whole house
uh will support that
britain has reiterated its promise to
help ukraine and that help is
desperately needed refugees continue to
pour across her borders
these are the first to arrive in berlin
the german city itself no stranger to
the brutality of war
she's josh he's sky leaves